The joe rogan experience character cause cause I've done that where I've gone
over to the line and I've said things that I don't believe in.
It made me feel bad later.
Yeah.
I opened for Nirvana and uh,
and know comics are always like,
oh you know,
getting heckled and stuff,
you know.
I mean I got hit with teenagers,
they would successfully throw people from the pit and hit me and I had an
[inaudible] going off around me and I get hit with bibles a lot too,
which was weird.
Whoa.
Wow.
Yeah.
And so boots and stuff.
So I learned like I learned like the Serpentine,
you know what I mean?
I would just go back.
And how have the times did you open for that?
I did,
I think like 16,
17 shows.
Then every once in a while we would go okay.
Which was weird,
you know,
but I was more comfortable when it was horrible.
I know that sounds weird,
but that was my,
that felt right to do.
You know what I mean?
That's he deserved.
No,
I just thought it was kind of funny.
You know,
like when you get laughs,
that means the crowd likes you.
When you get like rage,
that means you have all of their attention.
Do you know what I mean?
Like Robin Williams is my good friend,
right.
And Robin,
you know,
he goes on stage and people love them and then I would go on after him when we
do sets and,
and,
and in a weird way,
it meant more for me for people to go,
oh,
Robin Williams showed up last night.
Yeah.
And then Bobcat Goldthwait was dead.
You know what that fucking asshole said?
You know,
in a weird way that meant more to me,
you know,
his form of neuroses is way more lucrative.
You know,
I'm telling people to fuck off isn't as lucrative.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
so it was opening for Nirvana and Chicago and Michael Jordan and retired from
basketball.
And I went,
hey,
Chicago,
by the way,
they hated me to begin with,
but I go,
hey,
Chicago,
I feel bad,
but you know,
for $40 million a year,
I'd shoot my own dad in the fucking head,
you know?
Oh.
And there was a noise that wasn't even like a Bu.
It was just
like,
fuck you.
I wish I had that sample.
It was the best known
and knew.
What did you think at that moment when you heard that?
It was funny,
you know,
but,
but I did,
you know,
I don't have a beef with Michael Jordan.
I felt bad.
I mean,
even though,
cause people just because they're super famous doesn't mean they're still not
human.
So I did,
I go,
why'd I do that?
But you know,
so he had to live in,
you learn it's baby steps.
But the only person laughing that night really was,
I remember walking by Kurt on the amp and he goes,
I can't believe you said that.
But yeah,
I had,
uh,
met,
Nirvana.
I met Kurt before they broke.
He was a fan of mine and wanted to interview me.
So he interviewed me at a college radio station in Anarbor.
I know that blows people's minds.
It's like finding out that like a Jimmy Hendrix really loved Buddy Hackett or
something.
But,
uh,
but he did,
I,
he did.
He,
dude,
I love that.
Talking Duck Moose
blew my mind.
Wow.
That's pretty fucking cool.
I toured in the open form.
I repelled in nude from the roof of the Oakland Coliseum on new years when the
with them cause they were playing there.
And uh,
and uh,
yeah.
Did you meet Courtney?
Where you around court a little bit?
Did you see their relationship?
I mean,
the,
what I saw actually I don't have many,
uh,
any good dirt for people.
They seem to like each other.
I'm not,
you know,
I,
uh,
you know,
I think people,
I,
you know,
people get it well done,
all this crazy conspiracy stuff and all that stuff.
I think what happens with some things,
and I know where I am when I'm talking about crazy conspiracy,
but sometimes I think like huge tragedies happen and people can't justify them,
so they have to make up some other thing.
You know what I'm saying?
I think sometimes it's,
it's,
it's just,
um,
you know,
I,
Kurt was a really sweet guy,
but he certainly was a,
a manic depressive.
And I almost think like,
again,
when we're talking about drugs earlier,
people are talking about drugs.
It's like,
like that killed them.
well that didn't really kill him.
You know,
he,
he had some in his system when he died,
but he,
he,
he cleaned up enough to commit suicide.
You know,
there's some people that are chemical imbalances.
There's some people that are prone to suicide.
And I think blaming drugs is really lazy,
you know?
Well certainly upsets the balance though,
right?
I mean,
I have weird,
I'm 30 years sober and I'm saying this,
but,
but you know,
I think it's just easy to blame drugs.
Do you have any,
did you document your time with a nirvana at all or with curt or anything like
that at that time too?
Did you have like video cam quarters and you kept around?
I have a,
I have,
I have seen a photo of me nude behind him on stage with,
I have the Nutro wings on and then I'm naked with a repelling little thing.
And then,
uh,
I love him back.
And I also have a hat on.
I like the,
I don't mind people seeing my dick when my love handles,
but not my balding pate.
So I've got a hat.
Uh,
I will say this,
if you're a comedian and performer and you're going to be nude publicly,
give it a tug.
You'll,
you'll thank me later cause uh,
uh,
yeah,
it was cold.
I really wish I did pull my Dick.
How many photos are there of that out there?
Surprising.
Not a ton.
You know,
this was,
uh,
was in the mid nineties,
I guessing,
right.
Even have digital cameras.
So now it would have been everybody's phone,
but still,
I mean,
it wasn't hot.
It was just weird,
you know,
there was so much,
man,
I'm going on stage too,
by the way,
cause it was midnight,
you know,
fireworks were going off.
It was just like,
oh yeah.
And there's Bob Scratch,
Goldfarb nude walking around like a chair.
I was,
we were going to,
the way that it was set up,
the,
uh,
it was men,
you know,
New Year's.
So they wanted to do an extra thing where there's explosions.
And I,
and I remember saying the,
uh,
I said,
you know,
I go,
fuck you man.
I'm tired of being your scatter.
That was Elvis's chimp,
you know,
fuck you man.
I don't want to cheer you up,
you know,
go called Pauly shore's something,
you know.
So,
uh,
when we,
we set up the thing about me rip peddling,
the guy took a cold,
the stage manager took cold cuts and he built the stage out of the,
out of the food tray in the back.
And he's like,
okay,
here's what Chris's,
here's Dave years,
Kurt and Bob's going to repel in noon.
And these m and m's are where the explosives are.
And so,
and so,
um,
I,
it's still,
they go,
Kurt will count,
we'll tell you when it's midnight,
you count back from 10 or whatever,
you know,
and uh,
and the,
okay,
so,
uh,
it's midnight and they give him the sing though,
and he looks up and I'm holding my own weight,
like rappelling down,
but I stopped,
you know,
so he can count.
And so I'm giving them the Brown.
I basically,
from 150 feet up,
he goes,
he looks up and he goes,
Hey Oakland,
you wanna hear a drum solo.
And so I'm barely coming out of my own way.
And then finally he just goes one.
And I,
and I shot down really fast.
I had rope burns on my ass and sound like,
and I landed right behind him,
Bam.
And then,
uh,
I came down so fast,
he actually didn't see it.
And then he like,
he looks up and he's like,
Paulie,
Paulie.
So,
and so then I ducked behind this amp looking for a cover because they're
supposed to be when my clothes are supposed to be there,
but someone had taken him as a joke,
you know?
And so I just kinda had to stand in the middle of the stage because everywhere
there was bombs going off,
I learned this as if you're nude at midnight,
you don't get a kiss.
Like everywhere I went,
people were like,
Whoa,
nude guy walking around.
A little weird.
So yeah,
so again,
all of this was in sobriety.
Wow.
[inaudible].